let's bring in the nation's doctor
Surgeon General dr. Jerome Adams one of
our favorite people in public service
could you sir explain to us the virus
and some of the unknowns because it
feels like we learn a little bit more
every day about how it might be
transmitted well Dana thank you for
having me and I want to be straight with
the American people I want them to know
that this virus is a new situation that
is changing we're learning about it each
and every day but I do want America to
know that the risk right now is is low
to the average American we know there
are higher risk groups we know that if
you are older if you have medical
comorbidities such as diabetes heart
disease or lung disease you are at
higher risk but I want to give you some
perspective really quickly 18,000 people
have died of the flu in this country
this year so far and as you mentioned at
the top 11 people have died from corona
virus and while our hearts go out to
each and every family who's lost an
individual it's an important that we
keep things in perspective and we
recognize that we can do things to keep
our country safe we have a list of the
tips to prevent it they're the ones
we've been hearing about you avoid being
around people that are sick avoid
touching eyes nose and mouth and you
stay home and you know wash your hands
frequently and then there's also these
recommendations from the CDC about a
face mask
I loved your tweet the other day what do
you think about face masks well it's
important for folks to know that face
masks are not recommended for the
general public there there are two
things people should know number one if
you wear a face mask and you're not
wearing it properly you're going to be
more likely to touch your face and you
can actually increase your risk of
getting a respiratory disease like
corona virus or flu number two when
people hoard masks they are not
available for health care providers who
actually need them so my advice to folks
stop buying masks if you're part of the
general public leave them for the
healthcare provider so they can take
care of people who are sick I was
reading about a couple of universities
out on the west coast suggesting that
their students not travel out of the
country for their Spring Break
you know everybody likes to go and have
a big party they're encouraging them to
stay in the United States is that
something you think is a good idea well
I I don't know that we're quite
there yet but I think that every
institution every state needs to be
thinking about this I just got off the
phone with the governor of Ohio we
talked with the governor of Connecticut
earlier this week and the vice president
and I were in Florida talking to the
governor there last week we want people
to review their preparedness plans we
want them to think about what their
triggers should be because what folks
need to remember is these decisions are
made at the state and local level not at
the federal level and they're going to
be different in Seattle you you may do
different things in terms of closures
than what you would do on Ohio or
Connecticut right now but we've been
here before
MERS SARS h1n1 we have preparedness
plans and now's the time for people to
execute those preparedness plans and
make sure they're making the right
decisions for the people in their states
and communities I have two last
questions for you one of them is that
because there are going there's going to
be more testing we will likely see the
number of cases for people testing
positive go up but that's that isn't any
reason for people to panic is that right
exactly we expect to see more cases
unfortunately we will likely see more
deaths but again many more people will
likely die from the flu in this country
this year and then we'll even get sick
from coronavirus and we want folks to do
the things that they can do to control
spread of disease another important
thing is for people to get their flu
shot because when hospitals are
overflowing with flu patients they won't
be able to take care of people who have
corona virus and so again there are
things you can do to stay safe wearing a
mask is not one of them my last question
for you is just any advice you have for
those of us in the media who want to
cover the story responsibly to get
information out to people but also do
not make them overly concerned or not
undersell it either do you have any
advice for us what exactly we don't want
to undersell this this is a serious
global health threat but we want people
to keep it in perspective we want them
to know we've been here before we want
them to know we have the best team in
the world
Tony Falchi and sugar Robert Redfield
ambassador birx working to keep them
safe 24/7 and if we do the things that
we prepared to do preparedness over
panic facts over fear and go to CDC gov
for regular updates then I'm confident
we can get through this
you're a terrific Surgeon General
dr. jerome adams we love having you
thank you for giving us some of your
time thanks Dana did you get your flu
shot this year absolutely